Hey iodine manosphere bye welcome to
slender mansion there's a little story
there if you want to read it I can do it
and find it I think I'm in a coma and
I'm sunders after me my Sam slender
sickness that's totally a thing
sponsor how does that way
I don't I'm not even gonna ask
hey Shane acquaintance let's promote our
twitch o haste which stirs there I'm
gonna go there oh come on
[ __ ] was that anyway let's go find 12
mementos press space to drop a piece of
[ __ ] I have wine supplied Sam ah I guess
London wants a nice little run of it
with me oh you can go up ah
what is she pointing I don't know where
I guess I'll find that alright which
room first I think we'll have our way in
here hello hello hi
okay this is pretty nice oh I like what
you did with the place lender
ah happy Anna when the famine whoa all
right let's not play the piano
freaking Thunder man what is this a
donut whoa slender doesn't like me
picking up Donuts oh I see yeah I didn't
worry double insane sorry no way let's
carry I'm sorry alright so you need to
collect Donuts that it what is this what
is this okay gang ba ba what do you
doing that it looks really weird okay
don't worry I got this phone I can't
pick it up alright
it's just chilling in the hallway
looking at the window maybe he's
dreaming of the life he never had the
life has a farming and farming shell
like a frying pan
it looks pretty correct in size I'll
just take that thank you
that's right
it started creeping me out a little day
oh stop with a [ __ ] thunder holy [ __ ]
alright I'm going down I think we all
know I'm gonna die down here but that's
ok I need a key
son of a barrel well where is it then
this Tyler kid sauces I don't think
that's how you say it maybe Erina
more wine oh there you are
I can pick you up from there shut up
Thunder Jesus Christ give me a second
here the [ __ ] is he I don't trust this
uh whatever I'm sure it's nothing
how many do I have a scowl Oh even more
doubt and he put a little cell phone out
last night
how sandy you know I loved you you know
I care
don't touch my but I terrible you know I
love you and no I care
don't be a bear cuz I okay what is this
toilet thing Thank You Tyler
don't worry about a pitch call pilot
song oh I'm surprised I haven't made it
I another king come on alright I guess
we're down out of here
but the game tells me differently I want
to check out all the rooms actually ah
this is creeping me out
don't worry about breasts we have a head
call cut
yay all right little enough all right I
can't hold it all enough right now 5 out
of 12 I think we're pretty [ __ ]
actually what are you doing here what I
need a hell did he go oh [ __ ]
don't do that Jace's penis ah hey 20
that's that all right
don't even worry about breasts okay I
have 5 out of 12 I think it's up
can I pick this up ha ha ha
where the hell do I fit that in my
[ __ ] it's not that big I mean I that
is gay pants we're so good I shut up
Thunder all right I'm going out of here
I don't like it
all right I'm just gonna go hey Jo
doesn't weigh all right going up I'm
coming up
I wonder Slendy to know I want to let
him grow my balls back oh no I don't
know what I'm [ __ ] saying this is
pretty [ __ ] creepy it's not a shoe oh
it's a phone alright let's head upstairs
I don't know where she's PI Jang
oh there's paintings on the vast ocean
there's an are lovely all right so far
so good I'd say
I own the same once that bed it's on
holiday all right what's up what's up
sledding you can't scare me today
come here at that gap ass gap hi Oh
Marty dark oh no I dropped all right hi
I'm fiction it's Jesus okay it's
probably not Jay Z's buddy I guess you
should I don't like this oh [ __ ] oh no
no no stop looking behind fairy god damn
it why do I never listen
what is this
oh not out of 12 good kids possibly do
this no I
what was that why did he do that balls
that what ah is I hey coming in bed with
me shut up and can you stop holy [ __ ]
shut up and sleep with me come on why
don't you sleep with me shut up up when
I go in there what is up with these
windows nothing
by the way am I supposed to go that I
don't like this nope I've been in here
for sure I think we're done up here not
sure though I got 9 bathroom what's up
sometimes I do you have something in you
socks can I look at the toilets by
myself Jesus Christ
ah [ __ ] oh one more all right that was
not very long all right what do we got
over here we got the phone 4 out of 12
oh wait so there's four on each floor at
rhymes even holy [ __ ] I'm a genius all
right let's go down get four go up get
under the door because I want two more
on my nipples
nipples don't or do they I don't know
what I'm talking about all right we got
breasts I don't think they do let's do
it for the atmosphere that's right I
don't give a [ __ ]
bring it's not [ __ ] okay it's behind
me it's behind me he's behind me he's
behind me don't worry about it don't
worry about it don't worry about it you
got a done it I Love You Man what is
this fun to present more suds and it's
blinking now amazing don't be there
thank you this bathtub looks really
awkward I don't know what what are you
doing there
get away from me there you go stupid ass
you teleport backwards out my face is
chencang oh hello six out of 12 why is
it white okay cool daba daba Doo only
six how did how did that happen again
[ __ ] s there are anymore on this floor
though oh there's one
ah the king of cows now we can go
downstairs alright that's pretty good
I think we can do this press
don't even worry about it we'll just
jump down I don't know why I put it that
I don't quite it's part of the plan
don't even worry about it
I think it's this way no it's this way
let's the other way here it is alright
so far so [ __ ] good
my TV's turning off it's not good there
we go
I'd slap maybe you better step your game
up
oh it's dark it's most definitely very
night but that's okay
how's that it's really weird all right
come on baby we picked this up fine I
don't give a [ __ ]
912 I put that in my pocket we're close
breasts
we're so close we can do this that's
another one 12 out of 12 hey hiya dude
hey I don't like what you're doing there
on YouTube it's great all right what do
we got what do we add two more dots more
does Smosh
we're never gonna make this I'm screwed
I might as well just uh
ah
go fetch it but yeah just place yeah
just I love you you'll kill me don't get
me don't get me look at me Oh get me go
give it no give me look at me
I'm Chuck goes back to the engine back
with as many didn't duty buddy
why the [ __ ] is he on drugs why the [ __ ]
has had over clothes but never did it
goes don't get me please don't get me Oh
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
[ __ ] it hahaha
I take an exit
about all the blood there's a period
Locker now why would you do that
so she waits a period